that's pretty insane so anyhow we were
there working
we were working there we worked there
for a year and a half and you know
and we were used used on top of semi
semi-final on
the top and either one of the towns of
that and they come up to said to us
you know if we you know we
we can move you out you know now you
said you know
we have to start jobbing yeah jobbing is
getting beaten all the time and put the
new
new people over or we can move you out
and bring you back later
and move you to another territory and we
said where are you going to move us
and he says there's a promotion course
stampede
promotion now we never heard of stampede
this is a
notorious promotion in in wrestling
in those days every one of the name has
worked in it
and it was owned by stu hart we didn't
know who stu heart was
bret hart's father stu hart had 12 kids
that it's a notorious family in canada
and that and um
you know brent hart was wwe champion for
many years
and and owen hartness fell out of the
roof of one of the
pay-per-views and got killed ringside he
was on a hoist
i remember if he you know was in kansas
city come he was coming out on a rope
you know when they
have them down and it just the clips
have come undone
and he he fell to the pavement
on the paper views yeah that was a big
lawsuit
anyhow what was that so what was what
year was that
that was in about 1999 2000
anyhow getting back so so we moved into
the stew
we moved to that next territory and we
never knew
the first night we're there we're
working against the champions
and and we got disqualified you know
wrestling pre-arranged and yeah we we we
got disqualified we
started beating them up with the new
zealand flag we always
carry the new zealand flag right next
minute
these kids were thrown into the ring and
that and i'll tell you who by in a
minute
and and we were told beat him up beat
him up so the two champions
who we just got disquiet scholar from
the lying there
and these four kids from 11 to about 13
are thrown in the ring and two of them
are bleeding
and um i put we're putting the boot to
them and that
and then we leave we did we get we left
the ring
and we go back to the back and and we
hadn't met stu hart yet
and stu hart's there he said what the f
what the heck are you doing
and we said well the guy threw the
mountain said
the guy that threw the guys these kids
in the ring said
beat him up so we beat him up and uh you
know what i mean
because we came in to get over you know
the bad guys
this was televised yeah friday nights
were televised
in the pavilion you know
in the fairgrounds in in calgary there's
two arenas the pavilion which holds
three thousand and then now it's the
saddle dome that holds twenty that's
where all
all the big shows and and uh the paid
reviews are done and all that stuff
yeah and and the promotion did two sh
did um three shows a year where they did
the friday
and they did the sunday back to back
you know uh so anyhow we beat him up in
that now these were
stew hearts kids he didn't know and who
was throwing them in was abdullah
the butcher are you you've heard of
abdullah the butcher no
he blood crazy you know what i mean he
cut them all and threw them in
what yeah was that planned
was that planned no we didn't know he
was helping us get over
yeah abdullah abdullah is a heavy name
he drew the biggest houses in japan was
with king
brodie anyhow if you know wrestling fans
know all about that
right right here and a big controversy
with vince mcmahon
anyhow um so we um we put the boots him
and he told us they were his kids
and one of them was brats believe it or
not and the other one was
owen was too young at the time and there
was other kids
you know some of that he had 12 kids
eight boys and four girls
it's true and yeah that was our
territory so that was a friday night
that was played on saturday morning so
when we come to the show
that was a double header that weekend
the net so
sunday was in the big arena yeah because
they flew
talent in for a big show and when we
went out we got stuff thrown at us
that's how hot we we didn't get the
drawing power
but we were hated already you know i
just hated you you guys were noticed
that you were you guys were like the
go-to
heels yeah you know we you know we
didn't have we didn't have the drawing
power yet
but you know when you come into a
territory they
you they they feed you guys to beat up
and you know
get over yeah to get you over so you can
go to towns
and draw people it usually takes six
weeks if you're good heels
it takes six weeks of television you
know six television shows
and you're knocking the people on the
mic and you're beating people up
and by then if you're good heels you get
over and butcher me
get out of there get over to draw get
over
get over means when to get over to get
over as a bad guy to be main eventers
okay either to get over you know they
feed your talent to get over
get over means you beat them up whether
you win
win one two three but you get to get
over to get over as a hated
talent you know what i mean because the
the name of our game
is the good guy beating the bad guy but
you're gonna have the bad guys gonna go
get over as a bad guy to draw houses
how do you think that muhammad ali
people
bought tickets to see muhammad get
beaten he got over because he knocked
people out straight away
and he said i'm going to knock him out
in three and he blah blah blah
that cocky bastard we bought tickets
that's why
he got over so big because people bought
tickets
because they wanted us you think they
wanted they wanted to see him get bigger
but he always you know
really yeah and tyson look at tyson
yeah he was a heel too yeah tyson was
healed too
george foreman was a baby face he was
like
he was like do you know what i mean did
you did you
draw any kind of inspiration from guys
like that yeah yeah
we draw inspiration from you know killer
kowalski
here's the guy that went who who
muhammad ali followed gorgeous george
george's george was an old-time wrestler
a [ __ ]
you know he he wasn't a [ __ ] but no
he worked the [ __ ] gimmick oh he did okay
yeah and
over strong and he'd give out bobby you
know came out flamboyantly
he had died you know with rollers in his
hair blah blah blah and all that [ __ ]
that's what i did earlier in my career i
was sweet william
sweet william yeah did you come out with
the sheep
i worked as a [ __ ] i worked as a [ __ ] for
a long time
for the first five years i worked as a
[ __ ]
six years wow and that was in new
zealand
yeah and australia and you drew and you
you drew more emotion out of people
because oh yeah because i had
i'd had a woman in my corner or a male
in the corner and i slapped him around
slapped the woman around you know
spraying me with perfume
had rollers in my hair and all that
stuff go to women's salons
get my hair done is there any footage of
that on the internet i want to see that
is that that but i got photos and all
that
when i was doing that gimmick yeah whole
way with wolf flowery clothes you know
with popped out shoulders and all that
yeah
what would you say ballet shoes with a
crosstalk over here
yeah did you have to
in a lot of your matches did you have to
like hide a razor blade in your mouth
and like cut yourself make yourself
bleed
what are you talking about you know what
i mean did you have to
no i don't know what you mean you never
did that
look at my forehead is that what why
your forehead looks like that from you
cutting yourself
i'm not saying that but just look at it
i can see that's wild woman
wild woman with long toenails how's that
so you're not like you don't you don't
talk about that people don't talk about
that
well you've said it's been told people
talk i don't talk about it
no okay but um but it's it's pretty
gnarly like a lot of the guys that want
to make it and they want to get over
yeah they have to do crazy [ __ ] like
that they have to cut themselves
hey when they said blood capsules
there's no blood capsules
i've never used blood capsules at all
and i squirted blood out to as far as
where you are
bach i've hit main veins
on your face yes
[ __ ] i've got good shots dude if you
want to go and see bloody stub matches
go to go to the um
19 1986 in the superdome new orleans
the sheep herders versus fantastics
you